[Music]
this song right here goes out to all the
best buds
play this one loud with your homies
because
we're broke you ain't never had a friend
like this we're heterosexual
male assists
[Music]
we've seen each other's dicks but it's
not a big deal we've known each other
since we were taught
went from sucking on titties to jell-o
shots we like
dear palm sports post malone dearborn
shorts testosterone in the super bowl
root for the same team and we share a
big jar of creatine
do shirtless reps when we're at the gym
no homer but there's nobody better than
him
this is thomas tolls on the mic chris's
best friend
in real life i'll state that fact
explicitly
i mean chris turner specifically his
other friends
can't hold a candle that's why he put me
on his youtube channel
look at me i'm wearing his clothes just
one of many
[Music]
like our cheetos flaming hot when we
bring a chick home
is bottoms up keep our feelings like a
beer bottled up
hunt dear grill meat watch mma call a
cab then drive drunk
anyway i gave him a flavor do me a favor
tell these [ __ ] more about her
bro
behavior i'm just so grateful to be
included
now a friendship can't be disputed my
mom said he only
kept me around just a pedial cause he
needed a kidney or cause my sister was
pretty
well [ __ ] you mom take a look at me now
i bet the view counts 500
thou i'm gonna be in every one of his
videos
so adios haters we are closer than close
we're pro
pause get a grip nothing that you've
said is in the script
it's just a dumb song it's not a big
deal but the friendship we have is
entirely real
yeah sure man whatever you say for the
first
time ever i feel okay i know all of our
videos will be
hit so i slapped my boss and i said i
quit
i salted the earth i burned every bridge
left my beautiful wife fed my
this scumbag crazy thomas this was a
couple of videos and that's all it is
i genuinely think you need help and i
can make sure you get help
do you understand what i'm saying i
think so good this has made things
pretty clear
i guess i lost sight of the
[Music]
i have excellent listening skills
it's still cool if i get your kidney
right
you